on this sunday night allegations of
crimes against humanity they were
clearly civilians and they were executed
the world reacts to shocking images of
what ukrainian officials call a massacre
canada's sixth wave we are seeing
hospitalizations rising a warning we
should prepare for a major spike in
covet infections
printed sperm the canadian breakthrough
in male fertility research
and the long struggle of the star wars
kid within about two weeks was on the
cover of the new york times a new
documentary about the viral video that
brought fame and shame
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
chris galas
good evening and thanks very much for
joining us we begin tonight with a
warning that some of the images you're
about to see in our coverage of ukraine
are disturbing world leaders say it's
evidence of war crimes and crimes
against humanity civilians found bound
and executed ukraine's foreign affairs
minister calls it a deliberate massacre
russians trying to quote eliminate as
many ukrainians as they can the horrific
scene is drawing worldwide condemnation
it is a brutality against civilians we
haven't seen in
in europe for decades and and it's
horrific and it's absolutely
unacceptable that
civilians are targeted and uh and killed
the shocking images are being shared as
russian forces retreat from regions
around ukraine's capital refocusing
assaults on eastern and southern ukraine
abigail beeman has our top story tonight
more shocking images emerge of civilians
slain in the streets of regions around
the capital recaptured by ukraine
ukraine's head prosecutor said 410
bodies were found in towns near kiev
people with their hands and with their
legs tied up and was shots was bullet
holes at the back of their heads so they
were clearly they were clearly civilians
and they were executed russia is worse
than isis
in its in the scale and the ruthlessness
of the crimes committed swift
international condemnation canada's
prime minister and the foreign minister
who is about to leave for europe tweeted
about the senseless murder of innocent
civilians saying canada will support
investigations into war crimes to bring
those responsible to justice
unfortunately
we should expect that this is going to
be the first of many horrible
revelations russia's defense ministry
denied killing civilians sunday calling
the footage a staged performance by
ukraine
russia is taking responsibility for
these missile strikes in odessa
destroying an oil refinery and fuel
storage facilities its retreat from kiev
is seen more as a repositioning
strengthening their presence in the
south and east that includes the
besieged port city of mariopol cut off
from food and electricity for weeks and
key to a land bridge between crimea and
russia they're just holding out by the
skin of their teeth and this is
an area that russia is slowly
advancing on and using medieval type
siege warfare
and so the um the ukrainian forces
definitely need reinforcement there and
contested areas of the dawn bass which
russia wants to take entirely until
the russians play out that scenario see
what is possible to achieve in the
donbass i'm not sure that we should feel
confident that the russians are in a
place where they are going to engage in
good faith in the negotiations russia's
chief negotiator said peace talks are
set to resume monday but also that
things have not progressed far enough
for any top-level meetings between
russian president vladimir putin and
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
contrary to what ukraine's negotiator
said saturday abigail beeman global news
ottawa
as ukraine reclaims the region around
kiev american leaders are calling it a
devastating setback for russia but the
biden administration warns russian
forces might simply be regrouping the
u.s is pledging more firepower for
ukraine which includes getting
soviet-made tanks into the country
jennifer johnson reports
as ukrainian forces stopped russia's
military from penetrating kiev president
volodamir zielinski is asking western
allies again for more anti-missile
systems
the biden administration isn't giving
specifics but says it's committed to
providing ukraine with more firepower
the military future of this attack has
to be pushed back and that's why we're
doing so much to back the president
zielinski and his military with the
tools they need with the weapons they
need
zielinski's request last week for more
tanks is being granted the u.s is
working with allies in the region to
transfer soviet-made tanks into ukraine
the first time in the war america has
helped transfer this type of equipment
the tanks will help ukraine launch
long-range artillery strikes on russian
targets some republicans are criticizing
president joe biden for not acting
faster we should give them what they
need as quickly as they needed i think
frankly what the president's done has
generally been the right thing but about
two or three weeks slower
than it should have been trying to turn
up the heat on russia's financial pain
the white house is still encouraging
allies to stop buying russian oil
lithuania has now cut itself off
entirely from russian gas imports the
first of the european union's 27 nations
to do that we're working every single
day with partners and allies around the
world to make sure that we're tightening
the sanctions closing any loopholes
adding new ones the white house also
says it would consider giving president
zielinski the power to offer lifting
some of the sanctions against russia if
the kremlin comes to the negotiating
table and agrees to finally end this war
jennifer johnson global news washington
russia and ukraine are trading
accusations over drifting mines in the
black sea
[Music]
teams from several countries are
attempting to defuse explosives left in
the open water russia says mines have
drifted out to sea from ukrainian ports
but british military intelligence says
the mines are almost certainly due to
russian naval activity calling it a
serious risk to maritime activity
the war in ukraine is overshadowing an
important election in neighboring
hungary today prime minister victor
orban is seeking a fourth consecutive
term early results show a strong lead
for the pro-putin nationalist orban is
already claiming victory he's up against
a diverse western-looking coalition
hungary's six main opposition parties
put aside their ideological differences
to form a united front
frustration is growing in china's
largest city shanghai where residents
are living under a sweeping covid 19
lockdown
cases are rising here in canada as well
but as heather yorick's west shows us
the sixth wave here isn't likely to see
broad public health restrictions
reimposed
there's no official information about
any plans any arrangements we don't know
when we're going to leave
jane palabatko is under lockdown in
shanghai after the ukrainian tested
positive for kovit 19 she was taken to
this quarantine center at the shanghai
expo
here there are about 15 000 beds but
across the city millions are also
isolating at home there are no showers
here and we're not allowed to receive
any parcels from the outside world two
years ago the world watched china impose
lockdowns with baited breath anxious to
see if the country would be able to
contain this new coronavirus but dr
isaac bogach says things are much
different today we're not really
concerned about importing more virus we
already have enough of it here and we're
really in a very different stage of the
pandemic than they are thanks to
widespread uptake of mainly mrna
vaccines still cases of covid are up
once again in many parts of the country
suggesting that canada has now entered a
sixth wave we really cannot say
what our new case numbers are we are
seeing
hospitalizations rising four percent
uh in the last week fueled by the ba2
omicron sub-variant experts expect this
wave will bring more hospitalizations
and sadly more deaths but it isn't
expected to overwhelm health systems as
much as previous waves and for now no
canadian jurisdictions are even hinting
widespread public health measures could
be reimposed we're keeping a sharp eye
on it i always recommend people to be
cautious getting boosters masking and
staying home when sick compared to a
city in lockdown a relatively small
price to pay heather eurix west global
news calgary
canada's overdose crisis continues to
get worse during the pandemic with many
communities reporting record numbers of
opioid related deaths and
hospitalizations in alberta another
crushing wave of opioid deaths and
experts bracing for another difficult
year morgan black reports
alberta hit a grim milestone in 2021 the
deadliest year on record for drug
poisonings the newest data doesn't bring
much confidence to this researcher it's
really not looking like 2022 is going to
be a better year on friday the
government of alberta released drug
poisoning data for the month of january
160 albertans died of a poisoning nearly
all related to opioids though it's a
lower number than in recent months dr
rebecca haines saw says affected
families are still at a loss
i know
people on the ground
people who are advocating and caring for
people using substances
have been
begging
for policymakers to listen the province
says the numbers show alberta continues
to see the long-term impact that the
pandemic and related restrictions are
having on people who use substances it
points to resources like its overdose
response app and treatment programs
edmonton city councilor michael jans
wants to see a new approach explored the
system's completely broken and people
are dying in january he requested a
report from the city administration to
explore decriminalization he says the
findings supported the move we don't
decide at city council it's up to the
federal government but we can ask we can
ask for more tools and we can ask for
more options decriminalization is one of
them advocates are also asking for
changes at the provincial level when it
comes to drug use on friday a new change
at supervised consumption sites began
asking people for their id before entry
the province says the change will
connect clients better to health care
critics aren't convinced i don't think
we can guarantee that it won't be a
major deterrent haynes says the deaths
within the data aren't getting easier to
handle i get really emotional like i
it's not something i'm immune to yet
like
it does bring tears to my eyes she hopes
change comes soon
morgan black global news
in california at least six people are
dead and 12 others recovering after a
mass shooting in downtown sacramento it
happened around two o'clock in the
morning police say they were patrolling
the area when they heard gunfire and
rushed to the scene just steps away from
sacramento's city hall an area that's
packed with bars and restaurants video
posted to social media shows people
running through the street the sound of
rapid gunfire and ambulances appearing
on scene
how many
unending tragedies does it take before
we begin to cure the sickness
in this country i'm heartbroken
and i'm outraged
i'm outraged
our community deserves better than this
investigators still don't know if it was
one or more suspects involved police are
calling for anyone with video recordings
on their phones to come forward
coming up canadian cities facing
millions of dollars in back pay find out
they might get some relief from ottawa
taxpayers are on the hook for millions
of dollars in back pay for rcmp officers
the canadian government and the national
police federation union ratified their
first ever collective agreement last
year it includes pay hikes that go back
to 2017 and municipalities are expected
to foot that bill but as katherine
urquhart explains ottawa is hinting it
might step in to help
members of the rcmp ratified their first
collective agreement last year
now local and provincial governments are
receiving bills in the millions to cover
retroactive pay there's going to be
a retroactive payment
of about 9 to 10 million dollars
and that goes back to 2017. richmond
bc's mayor says the city set aside funds
but not enough noting that retro
payments and annual pay raises will have
a significant impact it's a big hit on
our budget
at a time when we can ill afford it and
so we're looking for some compensation
and some help going forward
bc's 2020 police resources report shows
there are 65 municipal services with
more than 4 000 members provincial
services have another 2600 members so
retro pay is owed to an estimated 6600
members
surrey home to canada's largest
municipal rcmp force will foot the
largest bill
estimated at a staggering
46.62 million dollars the city says it
did not have a role in negotiating the
agreement and the federal government
does not take into account a city's
ability to pay hi mr in ottawa wednesday
global news asked canada's minister of
public safety will the federal
government help municipalities the short
answer is is yes we're working very
closely with municipalities as well as
with
provincial governments who contract the
rcmp as the police of jurisdiction no
details were provided in response the
union of bc municipalities told global
news the minister does not appear to be
saying anything new or substantive
and there was this from bc's public
safety minister local government has
been working
on this issue they have known that these
costs have been coming
for a number of years retroactive pay is
owed to approximately twenty thousand
mounties nationally whether that money
is delivered by local government or the
feds ultimately it will come from
taxpayers
catherine ercart global news vancouver
just ahead canadian researchers print up
a breakthrough in male infertility
in canada about one in six couples
struggle with infertility thirty percent
of the time the inability to conceive is
related to the male partner and often
it's not treatable but thanks to a team
of canadian researchers and clever use
of a 3d printer
some of those men are a step closer to
conceiving jamie morocco shows us how it
works
inside this vancouver lab the printers
aren't for paper
instead they're being used in hopes of
producing something unexpected sperm we
wanted to
really replicate what we see within the
natural human body and try to create
these tubules that are about the same
size as what we see in the actual
testicle so that gives us a pretty good
buffer in a world first dr ryan flanagan
and his team at the university of
british columbia 3d printed viable
testicular cells using stem cells they
obtained from a testicular biopsy from a
31 year old patient with non-obstructive
azospermia or noa where no sperm is
found in the ejaculate the team cultured
the cells when those continued to show a
positive viability rate they were 3d
printed onto a petri dish into a hollow
tube-like structure resembling the
sperm-producing tubules found inside the
testicles 12 days later the cells had
not only survived but thrived we got
partway to creating a full sperm so we
arrived at a middle stage of
that sperm production process for men
diagnosed with noa the current option is
surgery which can be invasive and
ineffective global experts say this
study is a game changer when you take
that hope away from patients where they
can't have kids and tell them there's no
option
and then you bring forward an option
such as what dr flanagan is proposing
that could make a huge difference
in the world of infertility flanagan is
motivated by the patients he hasn't been
able to help he says his team will now
try to coach the printed cells to
produce sperm facilitating cell to cell
interaction this is really the starting
point for for our research with the end
goal of giving more men the opportunity
to become biological fathers jamie
morocco global news toronto
coming up the story of the star wars kid
takes a dramatic turn
oh my god
this was in our bed
the entertainment world is looking back
at the life and legacy of new york
actress estelle harris who has died of
natural causes most famous for her
namesake role playing estelle george
costanz's mom on seinfeld harris began
her career quite late at the age of 50.
she also played mrs potato head in
pixar's toy story franchise and those
who worked with harris say she had one
of the best voices and best laughs of
anyone in the business estelle harris
was 93 years old
well if you were to write a book on the
history of the internet the chapter on
viral videos would have to include the
story of a quebec teen nineteen years
ago before social media or youtube a
video of jaslane reza exploded online
and he became known as the star wars kid
raza has rarely spoken about what
happened but he's breaking his silence
in a new national film board documentary
mike armstrong reports
it has somewhere in the neighborhood of
a billion views a number that's still
growing but it was in those first days
after shooting this video something no
one was ever supposed to see
that things exploded
within about two weeks it was on the
cover of the new york times gisleraza
was only 15 years old when classmates
found a video cassette he'd shot at
school
they uploaded his video to the web and
it snowballed
he blotted sounds and effects and it
kept growing
when producers from leno and letterman
and admittedly this journalist reached
out he and his parents turned down every
interview request
the fear was that people weren't
laughing with him but at him
at that time when you have a 15 year old
going through this
i'm not convinced more attention was the
the right remedy but the number one
viral video on the internet is the
so-called star wars kid
now 19 years later it has as part of a
documentary shining light on a story he
never before wanted told it's not just a
look at what happened but also what it
meant he revisits the trauma how he had
to leave school and how the media
attention forced his family to move out
of their home
i'm just like but he also meets one of
the people who originally spread the
video american blogger andy bayo was 25
years old when he saw it linked to it
and named it star wars kid
i have enormous regret
posting
the the video
i haven't talked to anybody about this
this is the first time and i am
i'm just profoundly sorry
now that's something he has uh never
heard from his former classmates an
apology his family sued the students and
settled out of court he's moved on he
studied law and rebuilt his life he's
never seen the other students again
now one sad irony in this story is how
his image was used and spread despite
being a minor the law would have
protected him better he says if instead
of making a video he committed a crime
mike armstrong global news montreal
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm chris galas
and tonight we want to leave you with
children leading a fundraising effort
for the ukrainian red cross
eleven-year-old carl and his friend
ten-year-old rowan from hundred mile
house bc launched a peace walk over
spring break with a modest 200 goal well
guess what they just hit 10 000
way to go kids
thanks very much for watching donna
friesen is back tomorrow night hope you
have a great night
[Music]